-Thank you, everybody.
I, um...
I've got to be honest --
I'm a little bit envious
of the people
who are visiting New York,
because I live here,
and it is very expensive, man.
The rent goes up every single
year, for no real reason at all.
Every year, a landlord
knocks on your door and is like,
"Wow. You're still
living in there?
[ Laughter ]
I guess we made last year
too easy for you, huh?"
They should really change
the slogan of this city.
Like, "If you can make it here,
you could have owned land
in a lot of other places."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
"You could have had a house,
and a boat, and a real family.
Why are you doing this
to yourself?"
And if you ask people, they're
like, "Well, the pizza's good."
[ Laughter ]
I need to know
where the pizza's that bad
that New York rent
is the option.
[ Laughter ]
Pizza is just
bread, sauce, and cheese.
It's hard to mess it up.
There's only two levels
of pizza --
great and fine.
[ Laughter ]
Completely okay.
I've never had a slice of pizza
so bad I'm like,
"You've got to be
kidding me!"
[ Laughter ]
"Get this out
of my face!"
Everybody in this room
has had microwaved pizza.
It's absolutely disgusting,
but it's pretty good.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I...
I've been trying to stay away
from pizza.
I'm trying to be healthier.
I started going to a gym,
mostly because
I just got broken down
by all the billboards
and slogans, you know?
You're walking
down the street,
and there's just
giant billbaords
of hot, half-naked
sweaty people
glaring at you
with a slogan underneath, like,
"Hey, anybody think about
having sex with you today?
[ Laughter ]
Didn't think so.
Hit hat treadmill right now."
When you are healthy, though,
there are a lot of benefits.
Like, even just going to places
that serve healthy food,
because they care
about how it looks.
They want it
to be presented nice.
Fast food places
do not care at all.
All food from
a fast-food place
looks like it was made
during a riot.
[ Laughter ]
The bag...
The bag is crushed.
Things are squished.
Like, is the manager
in an arm bar?
How is there mustard
on top of the bun?
There's...
[ Cheers and applause ]
There are also --
there are also no fights
at health-food places --
ever. Never.
Because nobody gets drunk
and wants an arugula salad.
It doesn't happen.
[ Laughter ]
Nobody is drinking,
and is like,
"Anybody else
thinking quinoa?"
Never.
[ Laughter ]
But people do get drunk,
and they want nuggets.
And they want them now!
"Give me those nuggets now,
or I will dragon-kick you
through that
drive-thru window!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
When you...
When you get a chance, YouTube
"vegan restaurant fight."
[ Laughter ]
You can get to the bottom
of all those videos,
because there are none.
[ Laughter ]
And then, YouTube
"fast food fights."
Whoa! It is nine days
of video.
You can't even watch it all,
because as you try,
people just keep
uploading more.
[ Laughter ]
It is hard
to be healthy.
Like, even if you get
health drinks, right?
On the side of healthy drinks,
they have warnings.
They have warnings
on health drinks that say,
"Warning! Only drink
one of these a day."
Why?
Why can you only have
one can of vitamins a day?
There is nothing on the side
of a bottle of rum
that tells you to calm down
at all.
[ Laughter ]
Nothing.
The only things is says is
"Drink responsibly."
What does that
even mean?
[ Light laughter ]
"Hey, if you're
gonna get drunk,
make sure you're doing
your taxes at the same time."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Have a few shots
and go vote.
Make this a
responsible night."
This is how hard
it is to be healthy --
apples can kill you.
Apples!
I read a thing that said that
apples soak up pesticides.
So, if eat a lot of apples,
you can die.
Like, an apple a day
can literally bring a team
of doctors
running your way...
[ Laughter ]
...screaming
"Put the apple down!
You're better off
snorting Doritos!"
[ Laughter ]
If you are gonna be healthy, you
have to get organic food, right?
Have to get organic food,
and that's so expensive.
And organic food, at one point
in time, was just called "food."
It was just called "food."
And then, they modified food,
and they were like,
"Well, we can't call this
'modified food.'
So, we'll call
modified food 'food'
and food
'organic food.'"
[ Laughter ]
Now, you've got to make
a real decision with yourself
when you go in
the grocery store.
Like, "Do I want
the good strawberries?
They're not gonna
hurt me.
Nothing wrong with them,
but they're $5.
Or do I want
the modified strawberries" --
that are huge, too.
They're pulsating
in the package.
[ Laughter ]
You can't even
close the lid.
They're picking fights
with blueberries beside them.
But they're $1.75.
"It's been a rough month.
I hope these strawberries
don't attack my kids."
Thank you very much,
everybody.
Appreciate you.
Have a good night.
♪♪♪♪
-Oh, my gosh.
Nathan Macintosh.
You can see him at...
the Gotham Comedy Club
March 29th and 30th,
here in New York.